The challenges this world presents will create.
Divisions will create chaos and so on.
So I'm more focused on the way we deal as a society with that chaos,
the way we talk to each other, that's huge. That's writing the platform.
That's healthy for that.
Now, as a, as a comedian creator, whatever you want to call it,
people that put out content, uh,
the gatekeepers are now algorithmic, right?
So they are kind of almost AI already. So if you are a person that puts out,
you know, YouTube videos, podcasts, uh, whatever you're doing, um,
you are, it used to be a guy in the back of the room with a cigar saying,
I like you, or get him out of here now. It's, it's an algorithm.
You barely understand. Like I talk, I've talked to people at YouTube,
but I don't know if they understand the algorithm. They don't, they don't.
And that's fascinating. Yeah, it's fascinating. Cause I,
I speak to people at YouTube and I go, Hey man, what's going on here?
One of my episode, titles of my podcast was called knife fight in Malibu.
It was about real estate. And, and it was because a realtor in Malibu,
I was trying to get a summer rental, which I can't really afford,
but I don't think that's a huge problem. I, I, you know, I follow my dreams.
So I called a realtor and she said, listen, she goes,
I don't know what the government's saying, but she goes,
it's a real knife fight out here. You know, an old grizzled woman,
real realtor can scan, seek out the mouth, driving a Porsche. You know,
it's a real knife fight out here. You know,
her entire life had become real estate.
Her soul had been hollowed out or container, you know,
no one's made her common years, but it's just, you just loves heated, fun,
fuse fun. She's a demon from hell. And we need them truly.
We're getting rid of them. It's not good.
And she goes to a real knife and out here. So we put that in the episode title.
And of course,
I guess some algorithm thought we were showing like people stabbing each other
in a Wendy's. And we, we got like demonetized, did we get the amount of dyes?
We lost a lot of views because we were kicked out of whatever out,
like we were just kicked out. Yeah. And then I was asking YouTube about it.
They were kind of understanding. And,
but even the people that worked there didn't truly seem to understand the
algorithm. So can you explain to me how that works with,
they barely know what's going.
On? No, they do not understand the full dynamics of the,
the monster or the amazing thing that they've created.
It's the amount of content that's being created is larger than anyone
understands, right? Like this is huge. They can't deal with it.
The teams aren't large enough to deal with it. There's like special cases.
So if you fall into the category, a special case,
so we can maybe talk about that. Like a Donald Trump, where you like,
actually have meetings about what to do with this particular account.
But everything outside of that is all algorithms.
They get reported by people and they get, uh,
they give enough people to report a particular video or a particular tweet.
Again, it rises up to where humans look over it.
But the,
the re the initial step of the reporting and the
rising up to the human supervision is done by algorithm.
And they don't understand the dynamics of that.
Cause we're talking about billions of tweets.
We're talking about hundreds of thousands of hours
of video uploaded every day.
Now the hilarity of it is that
most of the YouTube algorithm is based on the title.
That's crazy.
And the description is a small contribution in terms of filtering in terms of
the knife fight situation, right. And that's all they can do. They cannot,
they don't have algorithms at all that are able to process the content of the
video.
So they try to also infer information based on if you're
watching all of these Q and on videos or something like that,
or flat earth videos.
And you also watch are really excitedly watching the whole night fight in
a Malibu video that says,
that increases the chance that the knife fight, uh, is, uh, uh,
a dangerous video for society or something like that. Interesting. Wow.
Based on their contribution.
Watching something,
cause I watched Q Anon and flat earth videos to ridicule them. Right. That,
you know what I mean? I watch these videos and I make fun of them on my show.
But what's interesting is if I then go watch something else I'm increasing the
likelihood that that video is going to get looked at as potentially subverted or
dangerous.
Exactly. That's why. So they make decisions about who you are,
like who you are as a human being, as a watcher divisional user,
based on the clusters of videos you're in.
But those clusters are not manually determined. They're,
they're automatically clustered has.
Uh, we have titles where they got upset about it. I don't even understand. Yeah.
Like we had a title that was so innocuous in my opinion,
and the title of the episode was called bomb Disney world.
And I was asking people to consider bombing Disney world
and YouTube got angry at that. So you don't know why you can never.
I said, Disney world is the bomb.
Rearranging. Probably man. I was saying, let's start. Yeah.
Thinking about their plans to do like not let's do it
like, but let's, let's get in the mind. Let's change the conversation. Yeah.
I think it's very interesting because as a comedian,
you don't want to live in that world of worrying about algorithms.
You don't want to worry about de platforming and shadow banning. I mean,
all of these conversations that I've had with other comedians about shadow
banning, I mean, it's hilarious. We all call each other.
I think I'm being shadow banned. Are you being shadow bad?
And nobody knew what that word was a month, I mean, a year ago,
but everyone now is convinced in everything they do that isn't succeeding as
being shadowed.
So it's this new paranoia there's algorithmic paranoia.
And now that we all kind of have,
because there are genuine instances of people being taken
out of it, algorithm, you know, rightly or wrongly for whatever,
however you want to believe.
But then there are also things that just don't perform as well for a myriad of
reasons. And, and then we're all saying like, well, they're against me,
they're shutting me down. And you don't know if that's true or not, you know,